Speaker 1: Let's go next to Jane
from Hollywood. Jane from Hollywood,
Welcome to the program.
What is on your mind today?
Jane from Hollywood. I've invited you to join
us. You do have to accept that invitation,
and then we'll be able to chat about whatever
is on your mind. And last opportunity for Jane
from Hollywood, please.
Speaker 4: All right.
Speaker 1: A failed attempt with Jane from
Hollywood. That is that is sad. Why don't
we try Ronald from Illinois. Ronald
from Illinois, welcome to the program.
Ron, please save us from the tech troubles
that are plaguing everyone. Yes, I can.
Speaker 5: Good. So I am first. First of all,
I want to say, did you enjoy your vacation?
Speaker 1: I did enjoy it. Thank you.
Speaker 5: All right, That's good. But this
knows with Clarence Thomas and Clarence Thomas
and all those Republicans, there's been no,
like all evidence put out. Do you think that's.
Speaker 4: Trumping them doing it?
Speaker 1: So you're saying, do I think
it's Trump putting out these negative
stories about Clarence Thomas?
Speaker 5: About Clarence Thomas,
all the other Republicans. I mean, just
because he's still. Do you think that he's
intentionally bringing them down with them?
Speaker 1: I don't think so. I mean,
that's an interesting question, which is Trump
gets arrested and indicted. Does he try to take
attention away from himself by publishing all of
this? You know, very sketchy financial activity
by Clarence Thomas? I don't think I I have
no reason to believe that's what's going on,
Let me put it that way.
Speaker 5:
All right, David, that was my question. Thanks.
Speaker 1: All right. There is Ronald from
Illinois. Great to hear from you